just hours after the romance between
Good Morning America co-anchors TJ
Holmes and Amy robach went public a past
anniversary post from TJ to his wife
went viral keeping the romance alive in
any relationship well maybe it's a
challenge these days just a little bit
sometimes back in March 2020 TJ took
part in the 10-year challenge where
Facebook users post two snaps one from a
decade ago and one present day alongside
a caption reflecting on life then and
now DJ used the opportunity to gush over
his wife Roc Nation attorney Marilee
vibeg writing despite my best efforts
she remained married to me the past 10
years TJ added that he gave her plenty
of reasons excuses and opportunities to
leave him but instead she showed a grace
and patience that's incomprehensible the
two tied the knot in 2010 and share a
daughter TJ's also dad to two kids from
a previous relationship the hair day and
the times I do her hair you have to 100
be in tune and we are that is some
quality time like nothing else we got
Now sources tell ET the two split before
the Daily Mail published pics of Amy and
TJ on Wednesday packing on the PDA all
over New York in recent weeks as for Amy
she's married to 90s heartthrob Andrew
shoe he played Billy Campbell on Melrose
Place
if I didn't know better I'd say that
sudden compulsion to have a diamond on
your fingers somehow connected to the
fact that we're having dinner with your
boss and his wife tonight Andrew and I
are in our second marriage we have a
blended family we have step children the
two listed their New York City Apartment
back in September for over five million
dollars and the three bedroom two
bathroom 2300 square feet property sold
last week yes Roblox is not here Dr
Ashton not here stuck with me folks
ah just take it in eat it up right
tonsil
um but yes those two are on the side but
they are working today that was TJ at
the 9 A.M anchor desk yesterday shortly
before the mail blasted out the story
and following the news A source told E.T
the romance has been going on in secret
for quite some time we will spare you
America and while we don't know exactly
when these two went from colleagues to
something more the mail reports things
shifted between them in June when the
pair was in the UK together to cover the
Queen's Platinum Jubilee this is the
Platinum party at the palace thank you
so it's nice alliteration there our
source notes that Amy and TJ have kept
it professional on set even when The
Vibes are fun and sometimes flirty
he always gets into the holiday spirit
why do I tell you things in confidence
and apparently the coupling is no
surprise to co-worker workers who've
witnessed their special bond over the
years
[Music]